before jump into the movie I want to
reminisce go backwards I'm going to
start with you
do you remember making starter for 10
because that was one of my very first
interviews and it was back in 2006 and
you can't believe the level of people
that were in that movie I can't believe
it I remember them all they were high
level people then we had Cumberbatch we
had McEvoy we had Rebecca Hall we had
James Corden we had a good we had a good
class of six I remember making the movie
very well a non-central question yes it
was a very very exciting movie to be
part of and I certainly remember
Benedict it is particularly making me
laugh a lot when I wasn't meant to be
laughing like that thank you jumping
into I get to talk to you both today I
really dig movies that deal with
technology that feels like it's this
close from you know being in the
public's realm if you will could you
sort of talk about that aspect of the
story cool it was yeah weird is in terms
of the technology we're looking at
cloning we're looking at manipulation of
consciousness transference of
consciousness and the possibility of
what it could mean to have a technology
of a transferable consciousness and I
guess that it's looking at it from a
heart side compassionate side and then
it's looking at it from perhaps a
capitalistic industrial side the thing
is that I really believe that we look at
humanity from a hundred years ago
and where we are now as a society and
it's just crazy how far we've advanced
so you wonder with stuff like this you
know is it a decade away is it two
decades away you know and if this
technology was in your life for real is
the stuff that you would want to work
with or you know what I mean well the
film is asking that isn't it it's asking
what would you do for for much of what's
going on you know I'm playing a
scientist who loses their family and
tries to bring them back
I think it's really interesting how far
away it is it could be five years away
it could be ten years away it could be
two years away I mean people are cloning
their dogs these are conversations that
you know I certainly hear stories about
the guys in Silicon Valley you know
already maybe living for 200 years like
these people did there's lots of things
that are crazy oh yeah I forgot in
mortality just a small thing yeah in a
family picture right what for both of
you when was the last time do you
remember the last time you both
auditioned for something foundation to
be you yes me no I did I wrecked with
you he auditioned with me he auditioned
for me ah
that's that's the better way of doing it
it's not what I've reviewed a lot more
than you I'm not sure that Keanu Reeves
goes I've been fortunate enough to
sometimes not I don't mind I actually
like auditioning but let me because you
rarely do it no no no no when I started
I thought it was a way for me to show my
perspective on it and to do it and it
was for me and to get to meet if you got
that far what they were interested in so
you were actually beginning the
collaborative process
you know you get no set to you a lot and
it's devastating and you just but it's
something that you want to do so you
keep going but yeah I've I guess I know
I'm dissing force
something's gotta give I had five
meetings you got it there right I did
yeah I auditioned with Diane Keaton I
think three times so that's mm and it's
not that far away though it was
relatively but and then I've taken
meetings and not got the job as well
that's always weird for me the meeting
that you don't get when you just sit and
talk to people and then you're like what
you just didn't like me like what that
was just a container of my personality
was have to do with me dad
well then we don't match with the artist
yeah it's just no key which is crushing
though it's still crush it's always
crushing it's always crushing but when
you're getting ready to do that meeting
are you getting ready to read with Keanu
are you in your head a little bit more
the night before like you know
overthinking situation definitely for
sure I was 35 minutes late to my meeting
with Keanu and Keanu very graciously
said what time did you think it was I
said 5:30 said well then you're on time
not all the time but definitely I
overthought my way into like some kind
of disaster with my car when my gas tank
like fell apart I mean yeah I ever
thought it definitely the thing is I
will say I've been fortunate enough to
see him work a few times on set and just
ear muffs for a second the nicest guy
total like just so nice it doesn't it
doesn't make sense like how nice you
don't I mean anyway he's also a complete
bastard yes Oh jumping into I definitely
have to ask you are part of Toy Story 4
how did you land this gig I have no idea
but I got a call which was really cool
out of the blue from the lovely people
that Pixar and the creators of this this
number
in addition or a continuation of the
story and they pitched the character to
me and and then we spoke and they
allowed me to kind of riff on it and and
I've done I think for recording sessions
with them so far and it's been a lot of
fun I can't wait I'm very curious about
working for a producer named Keano
because he could be very I was his
pretty wasn't really I wasn't produced I
was impressed I know he'll to the
costume problem yeah but otherwise yeah
otherwise we were just doing I saying
yeah
what but as a producer though I believe
you produce this what what is it for you
is it all in the pre-production process
or the post-production you know in this
project I really was I guess produce
oriole in the aspect of developing the
materials or more of a creative producer
than a physical producer on it cycle um
what talk a little bit about memorable
moments from filming I think you guys
film in Puerto Rico what was it like
filming down there and is there any like
cool fun stories about the two of you
you know on the onset I mean I
definitely got it on my Instagram the
other day there was a day when we went
we had to go underwater in a car for
five hours and Keanu was like so excited
and happy about it and it was really
awful and I was not enjoying it at all
remember that yeah
I've got a picture you took of me where
I look livid but that but we had a lot
of like stuff where we had to be I mean
we were often up at night at 3 a.m.
we just it was kind of a what it was
like a wild in its vibe it was like hot
long nights with crickets and mosquitoes
and the kids the young are going bowling
to get to know each other you know and
just yeah so Bob getting bringing you
out of the pod and all the good yes and
the driving the stuff through the woods
yeah a lot of stunt driving yeah but
then also those kind of intense things
that we have you know yeah we'd have
drink I feel like we drank a whole
coca-cola after each yeah so there was
some good work there and I think yeah
there was we enjoyed we definitely I
really liked acting with you um that
note I need to stop I would say we were
just um no no they're gonna throw me out
of the room I would just say I cannot
wait for John wave3 and is he riding a
horse oh yeah we saw those
[Music]